[Music]
I'm sure someone were to look inside my
window while I'm playing they probably
would have no idea what's going on in
here to watch a theremin being played
looks really strange my name is Pamela
and Stickney and one of the instruments
I love to play is a ceremony like what
the hell was that in fact I don't know
so the diamond is a synthesizer and it's
a synthesizer that's not controlled with
the use of a keyboard like a piano I'm
controlling the pitches with my left
hand and this hand is just the
articulation hands the volume
[Music]
it's controlled without any physical
contact and you can make it like a
bridge the really big challenge with the
instrument is it's reacting not just to
my hands and how they're moving in my
fingers it's sensitive as well in a to
my whole body I've recorded on an album
of David Burns Grace Jones the Indigo
Girls it's such a new instrument still
that there's nobody who's going to stand
there and say you're not doing it the
way it's supposed to be done I don't
think there's anything else like it it
doesn't relate to anything else has ever
played
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm the first woman to graduate with a
doctorate from Juilliard and now I play
the toy piano life works in mysterious
ways
I have transformed the toy piano into a
rail instrument to play the toy drama
well you have to practice on it every
bit as hard as you would on a normal
piano in fact I think you have to work
even harder because the action is so
primitive you can make it sound
beautiful you can make it sound
convincing it's a bit like going down
the rabbit hole and taking your audience
with you way back down this Avenue to
your childhood days what a skeptical
person comes to a toy piano concert that
I give I'm able to turn him around it's
a whole extended family now of people
into Tatiana's it's a fearless little
band and we're willing to stick their
necks out for toys
[Music]
[Music]
see page
c page play play page play what the hell
is page playing this is an orchestra
comprised entirely of fleets this works
because flutes can cover the entire
range of an orchestra on their own from
the piccolo at the top all the way to
the double contrabass fluid down at the
bottom very cool and there's Page
playing you know back from the intro
I'm page long and I'm a professional
flutist wait flutist or flautist
I like flutist she's one of a handful of
people playing the three largest flutes
in the flute family the contrabass flute
the sub contrabass flute and the double
conscious flute let's learn about big
flutes in its case the double contrabass
flute
weighs approximately 30 pounds it stands
over eight feet tall and it's 22 feet of
to big the sub contrabass flute in G has
11 feet of tubing and the contrabass in
C has nine feet of tubing so how does
one play an instrument with 22 feet of
tubing for these lower flutes it's a
whole different technique your
embouchure is looser new word embouchure
um sure
embouchure embouchure is the way you
shape your mouth to make a sound on the
flute your mouth is looser bigger takes
a lot more air and a lot more support I
feel like I've run a 10k when I'm done
with a concert because it's hard to get
a clean low sound they actually play the
lowest possible notes of an orchestral
instrument say Louis of any orchestral
instrument now what does that mean hey
guys can you help us out here well
alright ready boys the double contrabass
flucos low lower than any instrument can
go lower than the stream is a big old
guy he makes that bass on fly and what's
next it's the sub contrabass flute hit
it another big flute sounds like a
bassoon the sub contrabass can carry a
tune the contrabass flute is the
smallest fellow it sounds just like a
cello
wow thanks now I understand so Paige
what do you like about these giant
flutes in the land of flutes they're
like the subculture of the flute
community and we provide a role that the
concert flute cannot
it all checks out Paige play us out to
play the instrument that is utilizing
our gentle earth it's like you are
becoming one with the instrument in a
very true way you just sit and go yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're looking at the grates to leg pipe
organ of the Luray Caverns in Luray
Virginia when I press a key it sends an
electrical pulse up to a rubber tipped
mallet which strikes the stalactite
causing it to vibrate and producing a
incredibly beautiful musical tone the
area that the strikers cover is roughly
three and a half acres which then makes
it literally the world's largest musical
instrument it is a very gentle sound of
very peaceful there's only one like it
in the world and it's something
incredibly different and wonderfully
beautiful
I always thought you know a snowshoe
would really make a great cello a wooden
chair back makes a cool guitar body but
turns out that one of my most playable
instruments is is a golf club I'm seeing
that transformative quality in my head
all the time what can I say I'm
attracted to trash I don't know why
[Music]
check out the Jimi Hendrix of shovel is
a guitar made up of lots of junk he even
plays his zipper from Brooklyn New York
welcome ken vampire my name is Ken
Butler I'm an artist and musician and
known for building my own experimental
instruments since 1978
I think I've made around 400 instruments
this whole thing started for me when I
was in my basement in Portland Oregon
and I saw a rusty old beat-up hatchet
put two strings and two tuning pegs on
it
plugged it into my guitar amp and was
quite stunned that it actually sounded
like a horrible violin the ax violin was
the first time that somebody said that's
a cool idea
[Music]
if I go walking around the neighborhood
everywhere you look you see such amazing
conglomerations of potential sculpture
there's crutches tennis rackets parts of
furniture boom I'm right there with it
you know what I build stringed
instruments really just need three
things the head the neck and the body a
spoon has that parameter a key looks
like a guitar it has you know and then
this little body this is from a very
inexpensive mandolin of course some of
the things become crazy Baroque
assemblages of multiple multiple necks
it's ridiculous but that's how it works
my shovel guitar I guess it's a small
snow shovel it's just a four key object
and it sounds unbelievably beautiful the
qualities and characters at the golf
club ass is amazing
this one is made from a beach paddle
that has a ukelele neck and a team
sometimes people think my intention is
humour it's not
I think it's surprising to people when I
can generate genuine emotion and meaning
and real music on something as
ridiculous as a hockey stick or tennis
racket or a broom or a shovel or a golf
club at the real core of what I'm doing
its to communicate to other people that
the things right around them can be
magical and transformative and even
spiritual who knows if if I hadn't found
that axe what would have happened